alors voilà donc c'est vrai que c'est un
sujet douloureux parce que je pense que
le agression sexuelle sera un enfant
c'est le pire crime qui puisse exister
et ce qui est incompréhensible c'est
qu'il y a un silence effroyable
finalement sur cette criminalité parce
que c'est très difficile pour un enfant
de parler et c'est très difficile pour
un adulte de l'écouter et c'est très
difficile pour un adulte de savoir quoi
faire surtout lorsque quand c'est un
insecès c'est à dire un crime dans la
famille tous s'écroule d'une certaine
façon et donc je ce que j'ai essayé de
faire pour aujourd'hui c'est d'apporter
des règles des règles très précises des
mots très précises que ceux qui nous
écoutent parce que vous avez beaucoup de
téléspectateurs et je m'adresse à eux
parmi vous il y a des gens des adultes
qui ont subi des agressions sexuelles
enfants qui n'en n'ont jamais parlé et
si cette émission peut permettre à eux
de parler parce que la prise de parole
c'est déjà un début de guérison comme
expliquer manuel Béart qui parle 45 ans
après faut pas attendre 45 ans parce que
c'est un poids c'était c'est une
blessure c'est c'est elle elle est forte
elle a pu surmonter ça mais il y a
beaucoup de d'enfants par exemple ou
d'adultes après qui n'arrive jamais à
résorber cette douleur et qui par
exemple vont se suicider vont se mutiler
vont être à leur tour agressif etc donc
c'est très important de parler et puis
parmi parmi ceux qui nous regardent il y
a des enfants qui sont actuellement en
train d'être violés ou de subir des
atteintes sexuelles et peut-être et si
cette émission peut permettre aux
parents qui nous écoutent d'être plus
attentif aux bribes aux petites phrases
que l'enfant va exprimer pas pas
clairement pas
je vais donner quelques exemples et donc
il faut il faut absolument s'arrêter
écouter alors et puis il y a des
prédateurs qui nous écoutent donc on va
leur rappeler ce qui risque parce qu'il
y a beaucoup d'adultes je vais expliquer
comment est-ce que le prédateur fait une
emprise sur l'enfant comment se porte
dans un commissariat de police et donc
comment il faut résister à ce comédien
se pervers qui va se transformer en
victime qui dit qu'il n'a rien fait qui
dit qu'il est malade qui dit qu'il va se
guérir etc et ça non il faut pas laisser
passer alors il y a 5 questions hein ce
soir la première y a-t-il beaucoup
d'enfants concernés alors oui il y a
beaucoup d'enfants concernés puisqu'on
estime que un adulte sur 10 déjà a été
concerné et aujourd'hui c'est un enfant
sur ce une fille sur cinq et un enfant
sur 8 et un garçon sur 8 qui subit des
atteintes sexuelles ça veut dire en
effet peut-être trois ou quatre enfants
en moyenne par classe il y a des classes
où il y en aura plus des classes où il y
en a en moins ce qu'il faut voir c'est
ça parce qu'en plus avec la diffusion de
la pornographie les enfants
malheureusement ne savent plus ce qui
est bien ce qui est pas bien et le
prédateur sexuel va lui montrer des
images pornographiques en disant mais tu
sais tous les enfants font ça tous les
adultes font ça avec les enfants et
l'enfant n'a plus la capacité de
résister et donc la première chose à lui
dire
ça si on peut voir sur le ce que je vous
ai préparé
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire aux enfants
qui ne sont pas victimes mais à tous les
enfants moi je l'ai dit à mes enfants
quand ils étaient petits non pas pour
les accabler pour leur faire penser
qu'il rentre dans un monde prédateur etc
juste pour qu'ils prennent conscience et
juste leur donner une petite lumière
comme ça intérieur qui va à un moment
peut-être leur permettre de résister
c'est de lui dire ton corps c'est ton
corps tu as le droit de dire non ton
corps c'est ton corps tu as le droit de
dire non et vous devez dire à l'enfant
mon corps c'est mon corps j'ai le droit
de dire non même de dire non à des gens
que j'aime bien si ce qu'on me fait me
dérange et un enfant c'est toujours ce
qui dérange ce qui est un baiser normal
un baiser qui est pas normal l'enfant a
beaucoup d'instants il va savoir donc
ton corps c'est ton corps tu as le droit
de dire non on lui dit ça à peu près une
fois par mois il va pas tous les jours
parce qu'il faut pas non plus à câble et
l'enfant mais de temps en temps voilà
vous leur dites ça et ça ça les sécurise
alors pourquoi on parle d'inceste et pas
d'agression sexuelle parce que c'est ça
serait un peu plus clair je trouve non
c'est vrai parce que l'inceste et c'est
un mot qui paraît pas dangereux on dit
inceste assez ça veut dire juridiquement
c'est juste les relations sexuelles au
sein de la famille ça peut si c'est
interdit mais ça peut être des relations
entre adultes en revanche la graission
sexuelle en famille et c'est pour ça que
moi je préfère le mot l'agression
sexuelle en famille c'est 80% des
agressions sexuelles sur les enfants et
les autres ces agressions sexuelles dans
les milieux éducatifs l'école le sport
les milieux de loisirs etc les voisins
donc voyez 80% c'est dans la famille
donc c'est considérable quand même les
adultes ou les frères ou les cousins ou
les oncles les tentes les le père le
grand-père etc 80% donc c'est très
important et moi je pense et c'est
l'élément peut-être positif de ce soir
c'est que si la parole se libère les
prédateurs les abuseurs n'oseront plus
passer à l'acte parce qu'ils auront pu
s'amuser avec un enfant juste en se
disant bah pas vu pas pris non quand ils
seront que c'est 20 ans de réclusion
criminelle le viol d'un enfant il se
diront
donc il faut que la peur change de camp
et c'est ça qui est très important alors
justement il y a beaucoup de
condamnations quand les enfants
osent pas beaucoup de condamnations il y
a pas beaucoup de condamnations c'est
pour ça qu'il faut aussi une formation
de la police de la justice mais oui
parce que les prédateurs sont des
manipulateurs très intéressant très
intelligents vous voyez pas ils disent
alors moi j'en ai réglé en temps et que
ministre de la Famille et de l'enfance
et communiste de l'enseignement scolaire
parce que j'ai fait les premières
instructions contre la les abus sexuels
dans l'école c'était difficile
d'ailleurs déjà à ce moment-là et je
suis allé voir ce qui se faisait de
mieux dans les pays étrangers notamment
à l'époque c'était le Canada qui était
très en pointe et c'est ça que tous ces
éléments là de l'étude et d'examens que
je vous transmets aujourd'hui parce que
c'est très opérationnels
les abuseurs il s'écroule ils se mettent
à pleurnicher mais non c'est pas moi
mais non j'ai rien fait ah mais non
l'enfant ma provoqué
mais non c'est pas un peu comme pour les
femmes victimes de violence ça c'est la
même le même mécanisme non mais je vais
me faire soigner non mais je les ai
qu'une fois non mais j'ai des enfants
aussi non mais qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
devenir et du coup c'est très difficile
pour les parents d'être solidaire de
leur enfant parce qu'ils disent mais on
va peut-être semer la zizanie dans une
famille on va se mêler le chaos dans une
autre famille et à un moment dans le
choix inconscient qui est fait beaucoup
de parents choisissent de se taire et de
ne pas croire leur enfant et c'est pour
ça que je vous ai apporté ça c'est des
choses très importantes voilà pour
comment est-ce qu'on écoute un enfant
d'abord un enfant il va pas vous parler
quand vous êtes en train de l'écouter il
va vous parler quand il est en train de
jouer ou quand il voit que son père ou
sa mère sont en train de faire autre
chose il va lancer une petite phrase
et si vous n'entendez pas cette petite
phrase vous n'arrivez il ne la redira
pas une deuxième fois par exemple il va
me dire j'aime pas la taille mais ça va
dans ma culotte par exemple si vous
n'écoutez pas et puis c'est tellement
horrible mais ça arrive à votre enfant
que votre cerveau il va sélectionner
l'information vous n'allez pas forcément
entendre la phrase si vous entendez une
petite phrase comme ça vous vous arrêtez
vous arrêtez votre activité et vous
parlez à votre enfant et vous essayez
d'entendre ce qu'il dit parce que comme
je le répète le cerveau va sélectionner
et il va vous tout de suite dire faire
penser c'est tellement difficile à gérer
et puis surtout par rapport à qui il va
dénoncer qui va nommer ça va peut-être
pour une mère c'est pas peut-être son
nom donc le frère de sa mère donc c'est
très très compliqué pour un adulte
d'entendre ça donc qu'est-ce que vous
devez dire à l'enfant donc les 5 mots à
dire ça c'est le tableau le plus
important alors c'est dire mais même un
adulte vous pouvez le dire je te crois
ça c'est la confiance les enfants ne
mentent pas et les prédateurs savent que
rien qu'en disant l'enfant a menti il va
se disculper les enfants ne mentent pas
c'est déjà tellement dur à avouer que
les enfants ne mentent pas surtout à
l'égard de quelqu'un qui faisait bien je
te crois deuxièmement je suis désolé de
ce qui t'arrive ça c'est la compassion
je suis triste de ce qui t'arrive je
partage la douleur je suis désolé je ne
suis pas indifférent je suis désolé de
ce qui t'arrive troisièmement ce n'est
pas de ta faute car tout de suite
l'enfant va culpabiliser et d'ailleurs
le prédateur va dire mais c'est de sa
faute il m'a provoquer c'est lui qui a
enlevé sa culotte etc non c'est faux ce
n'est pas de ta faute tu n'es pas
responsable
quatrièmement je vais te protéger c'est
les parents protecteurs l'adulte
référent qui entend qui recueille la
parole de l'enfant je vais te protéger
il ne te fera plus de mal nous allons
faire ce qu'il faut tu vas pouvoir vivre
tranquillement et puis dernière point
dernière phrase à lui dire qui est très
importante c'est tu as bien fait de
parler parce que grâce à toi d'autres
enfants vont être protégés donc l'enfant
il va sortir de sa propre culpabilité il
va avoir une motivation et généreuse
pour se dire j'ai bien fait de parler
puisque je vais protéger d'autres
enfants il y a des mots à éviter aussi
alors il y a des mots à éviter les mois
à éviter qu'on dit spontané que tout un
chacun va dire spontanément mais
qu'est-ce que tu me racontes mais tu as
vu ça à la télé ou mais non mais si je
suis là mais il était si gentil mais
comment ça se fait mais non il t'a fait
des cadeaux il t'emmenait en vacances
mais il est très gentil avec toi
pourtant et puis après c'est la colère
mais pourquoi tu as rien dit avant
ou alors pourquoi t'as pas dit non donc
si vous êtes dans une posture de
culpabilisation de l'enfant c'est
terrible parce que l'enfant qui parle à
une personne référente ses parents où il
va peut-être parler à ses grands-parents
etc bah quand même Emmanuel Bernard la
part sa grand-mère
il pourra pas une deuxième fois revenir
ça a déjà été tellement difficile vous
voyez que si les culpabilisé brutalisé
il pourra pas devenir revenir une
deuxième fois est-ce qu'on peut parler
juste de cette dernière slide parce
qu'on l'a laissé passer tout à l'heure
et comment les prédateurs installent
l'emprise comment les prédateurs
installée c'est toujours les mêmes
mécanismes à tous les cas que j'ai vu
c'est toujours le même mécanisme que ce
soit la famille ou dans le milieu
éducatif et sportif au sens large ce
sont les services rendus la gentillesse
les compliments l'aide aux activités le
soutien scolaire la vérités de sport
complémentaire et l'amitié avec les
parents c'est à dire il y a une emprise
aussi sur le cercle familial pour que
l'enfant n'ose plus dénoncer l'ami de
ses parents ben là en plus c'est l'ami
des parents c'est pas possible qui m'ait
fait du mal et ensuite le prédateur
rentre dans la sphère intime donc il
approche l'enfant donc il a gagné la
confiance des parents il va gagner
ensuite la confiance de l'enfant et par
exemple et ensuite donc au début c'est
anodin des petites caresses etc puis un
jour il prend la petite fille sur ses
genoux et puis ensuite il lui met la
main dans la culotte et puis si la
petite fille était tanisée ne dis rien
il y a l'escalade après on passe au viol
et petit à petit il s'assure que le
silence est là et qu'il y aura plus de
retour possible parce qu'on dira après à
l'enfant le prédateur lui dit mais ils
vont jamais de croix parce que tu m'as
laissé mettre ta main dans ta culotte
donc ils vont dire mais pourquoi tu as
pas arrêté pourquoi tu n'as pas dit à la
première caresse à la première atteinte
sexuelle pourquoi tu l'as pas arrêté et
le prédateur va dire ben non ça lui
faisait plaisir puisque elle donc il
faut que vous sachiez de toute façon que
jamais un enfant jamais on ne peut dire
un enfant qu'il est consentant jamais
crime d'un adulte sur un enfant c'est
toujours un crime même si l'adulte
prétend que l'enfant était d'accord
parce qu'au départ l'enfant il reste
inerte tellement il est stupéfait et
donc faut pas interpréter le voyez
l'accord de l'enfant par rapport à cette
inertie qui est là alors les sanctions
pénales on en a parlé voilà et c'est
vrai que voilà c'est important ce soir
parce qu'on a vu Emmanuel Béart c'est
vrai que c'est dans vraiment dans
l'actualité et le gouvernement en a
parlé je voudrais juste qu'on revienne
sur les ravages sur l'enfance et le
dernier point qui est important pour
tous ceux qui nous regardent donc les
ravages sur l'enfance c'est quoi donc
c'est les maladies mal de ventre
vomissement échec scolaire trouble du
comportement troubles alimentaires
boulimie anorexie etc l'agressivité
l'enfant qui devient agressif l'enfant
qui régresse qui se remet à faire pipi
au lit par exemple ou à demander une
tétine ou un biberon même quand il a 10
12 ans donc c'est un signe ça très très
fort auquel il faut faire attention les
mutilations l'enfant qui va se mutiler
et enfin le suicide il y a beaucoup
d'enfants qui se sont suicidés on n'a
jamais j'aurais pu jusqu'à il y a pas
d'enquête sur l'entourage et au bout du
compte si la parole de l'enfant voyez le
summum finalement du silence c'est le
suicide de l'enfant de l'adolescent et
même de l'adulte si l'adulte au bout des
années n'a pas réussi à parler à un
moment il ne va jamais pouvoir se
reconstruire et jamais pouvoir
finalement retrouver un équilibre
personnel justement vous parlez de
suicide Emmanuel Béart c'est après ce
qu'elle a vécu elle a ça allait avoir
des envies suicidaires elle en a parlé
regardez
essayez de comprendre ce que traverse
physiquement et psychiquement ses
enfants
qui seront des adultes
en danger qui seront des survivants vous
avez l'impression de vous battre pour
survivre aujourd'hui ben je vais vous
dire une chose c'est que pour avoir eu
envie
d'en crever pendant longtemps je pense
que maintenant j'ai vraiment le droit de
d'avoir d'avoir envie de vivre on peut
en crever non pas en crever oui oui
très beauté merci Ségolène ça a été vous
avez pu dire tout ça
j'ai essayé de concentrer pour que ça
soit le plus utile possible très bien on
va le mettre sur les réseaux sur les
toutes ces toutes ces tableaux pour que
ceux qui ont pas eu le temps de noter ou
ça ne puisse leur servir et que vraiment
il y a une mobilisation nationale il y a
le numéro 119
une action je pense que quand il y a des
choses bien qui sont faites faut le dire
sur le 119
justement pour avec un spot publicitaire
qui va être publié mais c'est surtout la
prise de conscience de chacun ouvrir les
yeux
percevoir la bride d'une phrase d'un
enfant et ne pas avoir peur de protéger
cet enfant avec les cinq phrases clés
mais vous savez si autour de vous moi en
préparant l'émission j'en ai parlé à
plusieurs amis j'ai eu deux révélations
parmi des personnes que je connaissais
depuis plusieurs années donc vous allez
voir cette émission elle va susciter
elle va faire surgir la prise de parole
mais vous prenez les 5 points là les
cinq langages je te crois tu as bien
fait de parler je suis désolé de ce qui
t'arrive ce n'est pas de ta faute et
nous allons te protéger si vous dites ça
un enfant et un adulte déjà vous allez
lui voyez lui apporter une solidité
intérieure qui va lui permettre d'aller
plus loin merci merci c'est Colin
d'applaudissement
[Applaudissements]